paleta monsieur bernard debré monsieur
le premier ministre
cela fait plus de trois semaines que le
mouvement nuit debout occupe la place de
la république
l'état d'urgence permet certes ces
matches ces manifestations mais il
semble que permettent de tels
regroupements crée un risque pour la
sécurité publique
ces personnes pouvant servir de cible au
terrorisme comment se fait-il qu'on
interdise au lycée en sortir fumer une
cigarette dans la rue mais qu'on
autorise de tels rassemblements sur la
voie publique mais en réalité ma
question est autre je suis très inquiet
de constater la montée en puissance du
racisme anti blanc et de l'antisémitisme
dans notre pays
je n'en veux que pour preuve la récente
tenue dans l'enceinte de l'université
paris 8 de parole non blanches je cite
rencontre autour des races du travail et
de la mobilisation dont les thèmes
portaient je cite sur la blanche cité
dans les médias
les organisateurs de cet événement qui
se disent opposés aux philosémite ils
sont donc antisémite défendre la non
mixité anti capitaliste anti
impérialiste et voulant lutter contre la
négrophobie ont de plus prévu
d'organiser un camp d'été des colonials
destiné aux personnes subissant à titre
personnel le racisme d'état
dans un contexte français
cette réunion est interdite aux blancs
comme l'a notamment rappelé
l'hebdomadaire marianne dans sa dernière
édition
il appartient à votre gouvernement de
faire le nécessaire pour barrer la route
de ces mouvements d'extrême gauche qui
tout autant que l'extrême droite que je
combats mettent notre démocratie en
danger prenant le désordre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme
monsieur le premier ministre que ce soit
pour nuits de biens comme les jaloux
belkacem ministres éducation nationale
et enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député debré du 11 au 15
avril dernier en effet vous l'avez dit
se sont tenus à l'université paris 8
à l'initiative je dis ici d'un groupe
autoproclamé des réunions qui
s'affichait comme n'autorisant que les
paroles non blanches
je tiens ici à rappeler deux réalités
d'abord la réalité des faits puis
ensuite celle des principes
ces réunions ont été organisées je les
dis à l'initiative d'un groupe qui est
totalement indépendant des organisations
reconnues qui n'a jamais été autorisée
qui n'a jamais écoutez moi bien qui n'a
jamais été autorisée à organiser ces
réunions et dans un bâtiment qui plus
est qui était occupé la présidente de
l'université paris 8 a immédiatement
condamné la tenue de ces réunions
maintenant sur le plan des principes que
les choses soient claires je condamne
absolument la tenue de ces réunions
comme celle du camp d'été que vous
évoquez à l'instant pourquoi je les
condamne parce que au fond ces
initiatives sont inacceptables en ce que
bien loin de l'objectif qu'elle prétende
poursuit une vision racisées raciste de
la société qui n'est pas la nôtre ces
initiatives sont inacceptables parce
qu'au bout de ce chemin là je le dis à
tous ceux qui les organisent
il n'y a que le repli sur soi la
division communautaire et le chacun chez
soi
la seule réponse à apporter au racisme
et à l'antisémitisme qui va être un vrai
sujet c'est évidemment les valeurs de la
république dans toute leur universalité
et c'est la loi qui combat sans faille
les discriminations comme le fera la loi
égalité citoyenneté porté par mon
collègue patrick kanner voilà la réponse
condamnation sans faille et rappelle à
nous tous sur tous ces bancs de la
nécessité de promouvoir les valeurs de
la république
merci madame la ministre